oh you get me
I think you're the first man I've ever
loved
[Music]
I thought you had a date to go on I do
when's he gonna get here whenever he
does he's just like a few minutes late
hurry
so rude
a real man would be more considerate of
your time you're right that's why every
year People magazine names the
consideredest man alive
oh man you could make fun of me all you
want but when you grow up you'll see
what qualities make up a real man
someone say makeup I did uh all right
here we go
oh yeah much better you know what I
think I'm gonna Shadow down here
because this thing is really sad and
pathetic no
no tries this
some girls actually like guys who are
nice to them some girls like 36 of them
there's 37 of them okay this is Passion
we can use it Andy pick her up
all right let's just get this over with
oh my gosh he's actually picking me up
Dad this is for a minute now lock eyes
and action
honey
this is my long way of saying I miss you
I don't have to climb a mountain or
swim an ocean to be with you
because you're always with me
thoughts
my dreams
my heart
you deserve more than I could possibly
ever give you
but everything I have is yours
I love you
God
it was beautiful I really felt that one
did you feel that one no I didn't feel
anything I was talking to Andy
I'm just the luckiest guy ever to get to
love her okay she may be real but no way
you are who talks like that you know I
hate when you say things like that
because you are funny and you were
pretty and you were smart in an original
way so why shouldn't a guy feel lucky to
love you shut up be normal that is
honestly the best photo anyone's ever
taken of me thank you you mind if I send
a copy to Beth
Andy um
when I read the text about your flight I
saw the text from Beth telling you not
to come
she doesn't mean that
she said it's over that could mean a lot
of different things
[Music]
your phone's buzzing again
oh my God the wedding got moved up I had
to go
Andy are you sure about getting on that
plane yeah yeah I'm fine you know she
does this every once in a while she just
likes the drama but I Haley I appreciate
your concern I really do but I've been
in this relationship off and on for
eight years so I kind of know what I'm
doing all right thank you for the ride
hey Andy hey has the wedding started yet
oh yeah lots of times what's up
thing you said before about me serving
better you just meant like in general
right you weren't thinking of anyone in
particular
yeah no I I just meant you deserve to be
happy and if it's this girl great if not
great um
sometimes the hardest practice is
figuring out what you want
yeah
I'll see ya
I'm sorry if I gave you the wrong idea
don't worry about it I'm just glad we
didn't take it any further because
clearly we are wrong for each other
totally we are way better as friends way
like imagine if we kissed or something
that would have been a disaster
you would have been destroyed what whoa
Joe what's with the snow on the roof
you're aging like a president
um when you said I would be destroyed if
we had kissed what exactly did you mean
by that oh gosh I guess that is
confusing huh yeah I just meant that you
would have been emotionally ruined what
yeah I don't understand it myself but
there's a lot of heat coming off of this
girls do not get over this guy I'm not
calling myself a drug but I'm sorry
hasn't Beth broken up with you like 10
times she's dying to get back with me
though I wouldn't say it's withdrawal
for the record guys don't get over me
okay at last count I have three stalkers
one of them has my face spray painted on
his van I had to stand there forever
while he didn't okay
I didn't mean to imply that if we kissed
it wouldn't affect me
are you kidding
you were so pretty and so out of my
league it would have rocked my world
okay then it just would have hit you
harder that's all Mr Pritchett your bath
awaits
are you preparing for a button scrubbing
today so
oh no
I said something wrong didn't I
good right you betcha
ah come on don't be so formal come near
you
well I promise this little dude a bubble
beard come here oh don't be a stranger
okay
I guess some boys are a good distraction
yeah he could be exactly what she needs
right now I don't know about you but
sensing a little heat over here
this is so great and thanks to you Mr
Dunphy I can finally save up and get
Beth that engagement ring
Beth his girlfriend
we aren't together no no
she's like really obsessed with us
oh hey hey
been a while since I've seen you yeah
I've been putting a lot of hours in
trying to earn extra money for this
wedding hola I'm Dylan Haley's boyfriend
uh hey I'm Andy I didn't realize you two
were back together oh yeah we're like
magnets that sometimes take a break to
date other magnets what happened was we
were together
I was pretty hung up on you
but once I got it down to only one woman
in my head I saw Beth in a whole new way
and we were able to move forward
that makes sense
I'm happy for you
look at us brother and sister separated
from oh you're so good at that
hey what do you think about inviting
Haley and Dylan to the wedding
I love that idea
and I love you for having it
why do you think people stop saying
Quincy dink
Dylan
um oh God
you're breaking up with me again aren't
you I'm sorry I just I I feel like Andy
and Beth and everyone in the world are
moving forward and we're moving
backwards actually we're stopping
because I want to get out of the car
Dylan stop
tired of being jerked around
now I'm moving forward too can't you at
least call an Uber you know they banned
me for talking too much to the drivers
stop what are you doing you won't kiss
me you won't even touch me and then I
find Best Uniform so you tell me okay
what do you do with it anyway you you
sniff it you snuggle it you put on a
coat rack and dance with it I'm sending
best things back to her and I got her
uniform press because I love my country
so you and Beth your original Beth
there's only you I'm just trying to slow
us down a little we kind of started this
whole thing off in the middle I just
want us to catch up emotionally to where
we are physically so we don't burn out
we're not going to burn out I'd like to
way before we ever hooked up I just want
our relationship to be as good as our
affair
I mean we never even had a romantic
first date I know
Maybe
we should wait for the perfect moment so
we could start a relationship right
something special and magical like in
the movies
what do you want me to do chase you
through an airport I think we got it
oh yeah
I know we didn't get to finish our talk
earlier because of Alex's surprise pop
in
listen
if you're not taking that job in Utah
because of me you're making a mistake
I love you and me together but it would
break my heart if I was the reason you
gave up this dream career opportunity
because honestly I don't know how much
of a future there is here but
if our bond is as strong as we think it
is
we'll work our way back to each other
okay
but he said
so this is the end of the line no no I
told you you're gonna come visit I'll
come there nope I meant security
so none of that messy stuff because this
is not goodbye goodbye yeah we'll leave
the drama to those two
excuse me you won't forget me my darling
I love you until this pantsuit comes
back in style I don't regret a single
minute I've spent with you I think
you're the first man I've ever loved
not a single minute
really are the first
like a river
and now nothing to be done
[Music]